[Musique]
lié
[Applaudissements]
on voit que c'est les vacances restent
quand c'est les vacances et à un public
de vacances donc quand tu me touches pas
à bout il faudra qu'on voit kizomba
louis baillot mal à faire du sport
les billets
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces bons sont préférés du mandat qu'est
ce que c'est que c'est le gaz et
l'énergie
c'est l'ami de la vitesse fois le sait
la vitesse à la vitesse d'une vitesse
d'un liquide chute n importe quoi n
guessan bi dung so joe qui juste ta
carrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
j'espère que tu vas t'entraîner tu vas
tu
[Applaudissements]
à
c'est rien
[Applaudissements]
qui avait l'amour est dans le pré temps
rue du pré quoi n'a pas tout le temps
excellemment vue du prebat babar et vous
vous avez cole problème en patinage
c'est qu'à 19 ans parfois on prend sa
retraite mais je sais ça c'est tous les
papas m'apprend l'a45 ombre et alors je
vous dire si je perds ce match
aujourd'hui je démarrais toutes les
émissions tout nu par dire bonsoir à
vous mes patrons bonsoir cas pas plus
beau sourire accrocheur au soir jean
michel cymes a créé des jeux géants mais
devant vous à voir vos goûts et tous les
jours vous ferez comme ça vous ne ferez
c'est qui le patron et je dirais si toi
benjamin toiture alors que les points de
syrie sont souvent sur des fautes
directes mais
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment un sport de merdes
sanctions en cas d'échec
ah non alors
ouais
non alors je donne j'ai déjà donné
beaucoup beaucoup de cadeaux alors je
vais vous mettre devant un problème si
où vous prenez ce que je vous ai dit
heures on va faire tous les cadeaux de
télé est ce que votre fils lino adore
les kids united il écouta tout le temps
et jeanne fils alors il est je sais apps
franchement non ils écoutent des trucs
de nom mais il écoute les mêmes trucs
que moi je jouis bender jeu de melzer
faire quand vous étiez petits bouts
c'était quoi vous pourrez vous voulez
faire toi comme métier moi je suis
toujours voulu être acteur et non pas du
tout joué le chanteur
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]